Unknown: Hello, Russia, okay. Oh, I love you. We love you as well. This is my second time to be in your channeling. I was sitting in Sedona last month. All right. I'm from Hong Kong cosmetic surgeon and also do age management medicine. Yes. I'm US citizen for last 15 years I work in mainland China last two years. I work in Hong Kong. Yes. Now, everybody knows Hong Kong happening, you know, big tragedy.
How can you see things happening to in Hong Kong, from your planet? And my question is
who supported
This protesting and I cannot involve myself in your political machinations on Earth. Okay, how long it will last? The repercussions will probably last about a decade.
A decade. A decade is 10 years. Yes. From now. Yes.
Is going to be like a big mess. Now, last 14 years, the repercussions it will come down like ripples in a pond. Okay, you understand the idea of the splash, the initial splash will dissipate within perhaps one to two to three years at the most but the repercussions, the things that are connected to it, the things that will cause will ripple out for at least a decade.
Others will be affected in different ways by what has already happened. It will diminish over time, but the ripples
will last about 10 years. So what's the destination of the Hong Kong?
We cannot give you an absolute eventually, eventually. Okay. But again, you're talking about needing some time, probably at least two to three decades before your world experiences the idea of global peace in every single place. Because there are a lot of things that need to be worked out a lot of changes that have to happen.
is China governmental will I don't know how to how to see that we will take over or it's your be like make a peaceful? What is the future of Hong Kong? Again, you have to understand there's no such thing as an absolute future. There are many probabilities that you all haven't decided yet. So there are things you can do.
To make one particular kind of future more probable, and that is the sharing of information about the idea of being yourself being your true following your passion in the way that we have described, and everything, eventually, the more people that do that it will lead eventually to a very prosperous and peaceful, constructive future. But that's in your hands. It's not absolute, because not everyone will decide to do that. And they will split off into another reality, a different Hong Kong on another Earth. That won't necessarily be the same Hong Kong, you will go to remember, there are already an infinite number of Earth's that exists with very different realities on them. You are still as a group, as a people choosing which earth you will eventually wind up on and which
Hong Kong or Los Angeles or New York, you will experience so make your choices now to start navigating in the direction of the earth that you prefer to be on. Do you understand? Yeah, I understand. So that's, that's, that's what I decided from
a few months ago decided to go to all over the world to exploring to learn new technology, new things, and decided to watch War Two, I will do where I will go. So I was seen as Switzerland and Germany to study and then you may take all of that back to Hong Kong and what you have to share may make a big difference in terms of the direction and the future they experience along with you.
Everyone needs to play their part. Everyone is a seed. You water yourself, you give yourself enough light, you will grow others will begin to see you grow.
They will want to learn how to grow like you.
by the presence of your being. That's all you have to do to be of service and allow people to choose to change in more positive ways. Just be yourself. That's the biggest impact and biggest help you can possibly have. Just be yourself. And it will rub off on the people that needs to rub off on. But not everyone will choose to go down that path. And that's all right. Eventually, you will not experience any other path than the one you chose, along with the people that also chose a similar path. And if you're choosing a path of beauty and peace, then that's what eventually you will experience in a Hong Kong full of people who have chosen to experience that while on another Earth. People may have chosen something different and will experience something different. But it won't matter to you because you won't experience that world anymore.
That's how it works. You never change the world you're on. You shift to a different Earth based on the change you made within yourself.
That is more reflective of the vibration of that version of Earth.
Makes sense? Yes, it does. Alright.
Well, I am kind of confused. Congratulation.
That's good. Because what you're doing is unlocking from an old way of looking at it and starting to look at it a new way. And for the moment, you might be a little co fused with two different reality ideas. But eventually you will figure out which one works for you. And then you will crystallize that vision and you won't be confused anymore.
Right now you're in kind of a limbo state. Yes. Yes, son.
You're shifting gears. Yeah, well, when you shift gears, you have to first go through neutral.
So you may not really feel like you're anchored to anything. You may be a little confused out of your element. Not sure
where you stand not sure what to do. But that's part of the process to go through that neutral state. Because you have to do that in order to unlock from one reality and lock into another, just like you have to unlock from one year and lock into another. If you just bring the gears together without the neutral state, you'll strip the gears.
See this? So it's all right, enjoy your confusing vacation from one particular reality or another. It will give you the chance to really figure out what it is you prefer to do. And as soon as you really crystallize that for yourself, you'll mess right in to the new reality. The gears will click.
Okay, yes. Okay. Another question. Since I'm doing the age management medicine, yeah, I also do the hormone treatment and lifestyle treatment. Alright, so I find out some of my clients, they have two more and that the cancer Yes. So So
I wanted to ask you, what do you think of the cancer? What's the conversation? What is? Well, first and foremost? Well, it can be many reasons and there can be positive or negative ones. But first and foremost, in general, you're talking about the idea of stress and resistance to being the true self. Because then the body is not certain who it is. And therefore it starts to become something other because the person is trying to become something they're not. Therefore the cancer reflects the idea of them being not themselves by turning into a foreign element. You understand your needs, the stress is stress, but the resistance of not being your true self.
Many people on your planet have belief systems in which they experience trying to be someone they're not. You understand. Most people on your planet are not being themselves. They're trying to be someone else. They're trying to be who other people think they should be.
You understand? And when people try to be someone else other than who they are, they're sending a message to their body, that they are not themselves. And therefore, the cells in the body become something other than themselves become foreign and attack the body. Yes, you understand what we're saying? I'm kind of not exactly understand. All right. Do you understand that you have a particular path? That's true for you? Yes. Do you understand that many people on your planet do not walk their true path? I understand. So what do you think happens when someone doesn't walk their true path? What do you think happens to them?
If they're not walking their true path? If they're on a path that's not for them? Isn't that path going to offer a lot of struggle and pain and resistance in their lives? And what does that struggle and pain and resistance turn into music cause the cancer yes
Because they're not flowing on their path. Now, again, there are exceptions. Sometimes people can create that not because they need to learn a lesson from it, but because someone else they know in dealing with them and interacting with them may need to learn a lesson from it. So you have to take it on a person by person basis as to why they may have created the cancer experience. But we're talking in general, most people that create the idea of cancer in your society is because there is resistance to the natural self and the body picks up on that and therefore turns into something else other than them.
Yes, what is the, you know, two of my clients they are having the cancer now the having the chemotherapy and the radiation therapy.
When a good friend of mine she had breast cancer two years ago, yes and after the treatment, the cancer
disappeared. But now this year, yes, two months ago, it's it's moved to the lung. The underlying reason hasn't been discovered and been dealt with.
You can use many things to make it appear to go away. But if the underlying energetic vibrational reason that it started to begin with is still there, it's obviously going to come back. So the person must deal with the belief system and the real underlying reason why that person is not being their true self.
Yes, you understand.
They need to deal with it mentally, spiritually, energetically to find out what they believe to be true about themselves. Most of these ideas go all the way down to a very fundamental fear based or negative belief that is most commonly expressed as I'm not worthy. So there must be something
In that person that is allowing her to believe she is not worthy to be herself.
That's what has to be dealt with, as well as anything else that you might call a physical treatment. You have to deal with the source of why the body is out of alignment, which is always a belief system. It's always the energy of the belief. Yes. So the person has to deal with that as well. Otherwise, it'll just come back if they haven't dealt with it.
Is that's enough. Thank you. Okay. Thank you. Thank you. I love you. I love to you as well.
David Sharpe, and to you good day. I'm so glad you're here. I appreciate you sharing the formula with us. It's Breton me many interesting things. So we thank you for being willing to apply it in your life because that's what makes the difference. We can talk all day long about all sorts of ideas and principles, but only when you apply it. Do you get the proof that it works. So thank you for applying it. Good having the information? Yes. When Willow was with us here previously, she talked about the ocean and they have a process of de salud nating ocean use for water. Yes. Is there any information you could share to help us learn how to use that technology? Well, again, it's based on resonance. So they have certain devices that contain filtration systems that each vibrate at certain frequencies. That allows the salt to go one way and the water to go another
Lot of these are tubular in nature and the outer structure would appear or the inner structure, I suppose you would call it because there is the main inner structure, but there is an outer sheath. But the main structure is tubular but has many openings. And if you would say perhaps that it looks like it's almost woven in a crosshatch pattern all the way along, and there are layers of this and each layer operates at a certain frequency that distills out the salt from the water.
Does that make sense to you?
Somewhat. All right. Well, obviously, this technology is something that your planet hasn't invented yet. Therefore, it may take a little bit of investigation, a little bit of understanding of the difference in frequencies between salt and water, and being able to create certain kinds of containers through which the water flows. That actually removes the salt because it is attracted to harmonic frequencies that are representative of its structure.
How do we figure out what the different frequencies by getting the different substances to resonate and measuring what those frequencies are? And then duplicating those frequencies in a device that would cause those materials to be drawn toward their harmonic frequencies and pulled out of the water.
That's awesome. Well, yes,
it works quite well. How do I become more aware of dreaming while I'm dreaming? I don't know if I remember well, it can work differently for many different people. You can give yourself a symbol that when you see something in the dream, it will remind you that you're actually dreaming and you can become lucid. That works for some people. But you will have to find what works for you on your own.
Because everyone is different.
When I'm, when I'm creating art, or sometimes when I'm dancing,
I can feel something else come through me or maybe lots of other things coming through making it One moment.
All right, here's a suggestion that may begin to work for you. As we pick up on your vibration.
Tell yourself to dream about a clock.
Follow me so far, yes. When in the dream, you see the time on the clock,
tell yourself to look away and then look back. In a dream, the time on the clock will never be the same.
And therefore that might remind you that you're dreaming and help you become lucid and awake in the dream.
Okay, all right. Yeah, definitely.
Anything else in in times when I'm like, either making art or sometimes when I'm dancing, I think
feel, I feel like it's not me. I feel like there's something else. That's cool. It's more of you. It's more really coming through. Yes, of course, because you're also feeling all the connections you have, and identifying more strongly with those connections, which can sometimes be interpreted or translated as not being you. But nevertheless, it's just that you're experiencing more of the connections that you made to more of yourself in different places and times and forums and so on and so forth. So it's just more of you. Ultimately. That's, that's awesome. Yes, it is. Anything else? Yeah. But I've always had connections with cats. They tend to treat me like another cat. It's just my
is that my expectation that they do that or is it well, it's your vibration.
They recognize that you are giving off a familiar and similar vibration to them.
Is that awesome, too?
It is for sure. I believe you have a song on your planet. Everything is awesome.
Sounds like your theme song.
I think it is today. All right.
So Will that do? Um, you've said before you were expressed geometrically as opposed to mathematically can. Can you explain that a little further? Yes. Instead of using the idea of mathematical equations to express physical principles, or physics principles, we have consolidated the idea down into geometric forms. For example, you have what's kind of called an exclusion principle. You can't, shall we say, in certain circumstances, measure the speed and the position simultaneously of an object. Because once you measure its position, you have frozen the speed. If you measure the speed, you don't know where it is. You don't know what's
position. This is expressed in your physics along mathematical formulas. But from our point of view, it is perfectly expressed by the shape of a tetrahedron. You have innocence a four sided pyramid creating three
equals lateral triangles facing up and one as the base. You follow me? Yes? Well, the idea is that there are three points on the base, let's just say ABC or XYZ. And that represents the idea of, let's say, the physical position, but the fourth point is up here, not in the same plane as the other three particular notations. Therefore, it is up here and that is the component of time, momentum if you wish. So the idea is that you can have two components of space and one of time but you can't have all three components of space.
One at a time because they're not in the same plane. So that's an exclusion principle expressed by a tetrahedron rather than a mathematical formula. Does that help? That does hope. All right, well that do.
Why does it feel so important to be barefoot at times, so you can connect to the earth more directly?
Nice. Well that do. Thank you so much. Awesome. Much love.
Greetings, Bashar. Either you Good day. Just want to say thank you and Darryl, for sharing all the information you share over the years. Again, both of our passions and our pleasures, and it's very exciting to be here. First time in LA
Live event. All right. Me too.
I'm just wondering, I have a memory when I was very young around five years old. Yes. I thought I saw gray. I'm not sure that's not uncommon. usually starts that early if you're part of the hybridization agenda, and that's another question that Mr. Just answered it. Okay. And for hybrid children do I have you do have some genetic material and several hybrid children? Yes.
And also was curious, that ever die in chose to come back? Well, you sort of did. You've got very close close enough. I suppose that it counts. Okay.
And also, I'm curious, is there any information that my higher mind can share with me? About what, anything in general Well, in general, follow the formula okay.
You will have all your answers when you need them. Perfect.
Guess that's it. Thank you. Thank you.
Yes.
Hello Bashar One moment.
Thank you
Okay, so enjoy your good day.
Whoo. It's really wonderful being in your energy, honestly, and yours as well. Thank you.
Would you like to discuss? So recently a good friend of mine transitioned and how exciting for you.
Now you have someone on the other side
pulling strings for you definitely felt her. So I'm wondering if I shift into a parallel reality where she's still alive? What do the people in the other reality experience happens to me? Or does it just split into all the possibilities?
Everything happens at once. It depends simply on what is relevant for your focus as to what you experience of that nature. And others will create or not create the version of you that they need to say
okay,
How do you stop that from feeling too realistic or two?
How do you stop? What from feeling realistic? The shift? Why would you want to stop it?
You are implying that there's something to be afraid of here.
I guess it feels like the people around me are singular instead of shifting constantly. Yes, I understand that's the illusion of continuity in physical reality, but it's an illusion, you're constantly shifting.
Okay? It is definitely comforting to know that but at times, it can be a lot to take in. Well, it can be a little disorienting when you're not used to it. But it's part of the evolutionary process of your growth, to understand more and more and more of what's already going on, to be able to comprehend more and more and more of the shifting you're already doing.
If more than you're shifting, you just become more aware of the shifting you're already doing. And you can use it more consciously, to your benefit by navigating through it in the way that you prefer, in the direction that you prefer, toward the reality experience that you prefer. By following the formula, that's all you have to do. You don't have to overthink this or get caught up in the minutiae of the mechanism.
Don't overthink it, don't overcomplicate it, just follow the formula. act on your passion to the best you can. No assumption no insistence on the outcome. Stay in a positive state no matter what happens so you can receive the benefit. Therefore, in that context, nothing can go wrong. Whatever happens is what needs to happen. And it won't matter what happens because it's not about what happens. It's about what you do with what happens that makes the difference in your reality experience. So why be afraid of whatever it is that might happen when you know that the only things when you're in that state that can happen are the things that serve you
Who cares? What happens, you can use everything to your advantage, because that's how powerful all of you are.
So why not follow that track and stop worrying about the things that might happen? Because the things that happen in the state you prefer are only the things that serve you. That's the definition of that state. You can't have something different in that state.
Is this making some sense? 100%? Yes. Is this helping? Yes. Thank you. All right. And my last question is, so what happens if consciousness goes through black hole?
depends on the kind of black hole, but do understand that everything is made of consciousness? I do. So you're simply saying what happens if one form of consciousness interacts with another form of consciousness that happens to express itself in this particular way? It depends upon what the interaction is about.
It can be many different things. The kind of consciousness you're talking about going through the kind of consciousness represented by a black hole can have many different effects. It could allow you to experience yourself exploding not only into but as another universe.
That's one effect that can happen suddenly are a new universe.
Yes, yes. Thank you very much. You are very welcome.
Hello, today. Oh, hello, nany.
We have about 30 minutes left. So you have some questions from other. I do have a few. All right. You want me to do that first, as opposed to pulling some more names right now? Questions.
from others, okay, is what they're all screaming right now.
Okay.
First of all everybody wants to know, does the Is it a 24 hour period for the
event in Joshua Tree midnight under the hunter's moon, right so you can be there before you can be there. But they're trying to figure out if it's Saturday night because Saturday's the 12th and then the midnight and becomes the the 13th. So then you're seeing Sunday night which Yes, yes, yes, yes. Okay.
Everybody midnight of the 13th. midnight of the 13th which is a Sunday. Correct. Okay, great. Thank you for clarifying that. Yes, I'm,
of course people in Europe really want to know if there's any place they can
Go in Europe,
where they are Asia or Australia or this is a particular portal with a particular purpose and a particular event right now, we will give similar ideas, similar timings and locations for other places around the globe after this one that has occurred.
Okay.
There were some more
questions about Atlantis? Yes. So speak up, speak up. Okay. I'm looking for them.
What represents the best of the Atlantean civilization? In other words, can we aspire? What can we aspire to in this new Atlantis
the knowledge that was left in the chambers that exists will be the knowledge of the architecture. They've left behind the
incorporates many different kinds of cosmic and mathematical principles that will help you understand how reality works. Technological ideas that you have yet to discover will be in there. They weren't necessarily more advanced than you, but they were differently advanced than you. And so the knowledge and information that you will discover about them will give you a different way of expressing some of your technology that you may not have realized yet.
Also, ideas of more about how to propagate foodstuffs in a more natural way to feed the world.
Young
regarding Atlantis and the cycle that's ending and the new Atlantis cycle that's beginning Yes. Does this correlate to approximately the
26,000 year precession of the equinoxes No.
Okay.
Okay, this is a question that's different. There is controversy over the Joker film, as some believe it will inspire lonely males to violence against an unfair economic system in the West. Is this male centered nihilism related to Atlantis?
You're joking, right?
In general, yes, it is the imbalance of the male and female energy that was expressed through many of the males that allow there to be the vibration that brought about the destruction.
Could a human being naturally breed with an Orion? Did this actually occur in Atlantis? No.
You must understand that the ancient Orion systems that we're talking about,
we're talking about something that is millions of years ago in your calendar, not thousands of years, millions of years ago.
At the end, did the Atlantean civilization rely too much on technology and lose their balance with nature? Many of them did. Yes. Is that why you're always telling us to get out in nature more? It's one of the reasons that balance is crucial.
You remain grounded, so you can reach for the stars in a balanced way.
So this is from the same person that asked
The Joker question yeah.
And I'm not joking.
Speaking of Halloween, do SSID have any cultural horror stories that they would like tell tall tales of earth to frighten are
just joking.
No, of course not.
Behave or all send you to Earth.
No papa.
No mom.
Do you share any stories that have things like werewolves and vampires, Freddy Krueger
As I said earlier,
okay, um, but no, not really, we do not tell tales like that. And there are no experiences like that are there in our reality, we understand that in the cosmos, there are different kinds of beings. Some of them are expressing themselves in very negative ways, I suppose you would call horrifying or scary, and we are aware of some of them.
But it isn't within our culture to experience or express or discuss them in any other way other than as an observation of what it is that they are choosing to do within themselves for various reasons.
So like when you were talking about having simulation experiences for first contact? Yes. So did they ever give you any scary
simulations will know because there would be no point in making first contact with those civilizations.
Now, again, in making contact with Earth, there were scenarios that were presented that certainly confused us. Because they were so alien to our experience. And at first, we didn't actually believe the scenarios, we thought they were testing us to see if what they were giving us might just be made up. When we realized it wasn't made up. It was a little bit of a shock.
But that's about as far as it goes for us. Worried about it like a simulation where you, you know, like you said, you did they don't want to send you out before you have a little experience. Yes, so you don't mess up is but remember, we rely on our connections to simultaneous incarnations to do that.
You understand?
Well, in other words, you already know that any society we're going to make first contact with, we have a life in that society first. So that we can absorb the understanding of the positive, the negative, the neutral of that society, so that you won't be so alien to us and we won't be so alien to you. That's why again, euphemistically, the channel is one of my past lives so that in his experience of living on Earth, I can access that information and those experiences to be able to relate to you, and so that you can relate to us without those incarnational experiences in the societies that we choose to contact. We would simply be to alien to one another. We wouldn't understand one another. There would be no common ground, there would be no translation.
So if you were experiencing a simulation in your early training experience, yes. And you didn't know it was a simulation. Yes. So
Always, they didn't always tell you it was the simulation. They do it in that way so that our responses will be real. So we understand going in that it's going to be a simulation. But the master, who then conducts the telepathic simulation contains an element in that simulation that makes it seem to be happening for real. Otherwise, our reactions are not accurate. Exactly. So were you ever put into challenging situations? And but you didn't get scared? Well, no, there was no reason to get scared. There might have been many reasons to be puzzled for a while, but there's no reason to get scared. We understand going in that anything has an answer. There's always an alternative. We're taught that first. Remember, we have the basics going in, first of how things work, so that we can apply the principles the instruction manual, in our own simulation. So there
no reason for us to choose to be afraid of what's going to happen no matter how it looks. And some of our military they train, you know not to panic. Because panic kills. Yes. So this is a similar idea, then we'll sort of but we're not trained to not panic. Yeah, because you wouldn't panic correct as you wouldn't get afraid. We are trained to understand that there is simply no reason to choose to panic. It makes no sense to us. It's that ingrained. It's sort of the difference between a stable consciousness and a consciousness moving towards towards stability. Yes.
We are not moving towards stability, but we are I know.
Yes. So anymore.
No, no, no, I just was trying to find another question.
That I hadn't. Okay. So after finishing the 30 days cryptic meditation negative people started coming to this individual and interfering in their behavior, interfering with that trying opportunity to express what you've learned in the meditations about becoming a cryptic, so the person wanted to know how to be sure on the full moon. I'm not connecting with those or other negative beings How To be sure, yes, you're talking about the idea of what we suggested about going to Joshua Tree or some other full moon. I, I think it's Joshua Tree. Well, then the certainty is to not go.
Well, if you're going to carry with you a belief system that says that you might be in danger on the full moon, in Joshua Tree, don't go and then you will be certain not to have that experience.
couldn't be simpler.
Okay, well, um, yes. I'd love to go back and look at some of the other questions from yesterday in case we had a few. Yes, but
but it would take me a moment to we have someone else ask a question and I'll know, okay, I'll see this nice. Their timing is different.
Okay, I got I got it. So maybe I can come up with a few here.
Unless you're done.
How perceptive of
it is actually time for your short break before the holotape meditation. Okay. So take a short break, we will resume this transmission. Then.
See everyone in 15
minutes.
Don't say let us continue this transmission. Now, first and foremost, before we begin with the meditation,
the electronic experience that you had when we disconnected from the channel, is because we didn't completely disconnect.
We thought we'd give you a tiny taste of what's coming up on the 13th with regard to the idea of our presence being a little bit closer, by allowing you
to match our heartbeat.
So
this is the very beginning of things to come expressed first in the energy of your devices, but coming closer and closer
And closer.
Don't be scared
unless you find it fun.
And now, allow yourselves to relax.
Let go of the cares of the dare. Take a deep breath in and let it out.
And continue to breathe deeply and easily as you allow your lights to shift and your music to play
and to begin
the journey
to the portal
after midnight, under the hunter's moon,
because you can begin to project yourselves there now ahead of the physical
Date since all things are here, and now.
So be with us now.
In that vortex in Joshua Tree at midnight, under the full hunters
stand upon the ground, sit upon the ground lie upon the ground, whatever is your wish
and gaze up at the stars and the moon in the clouds of the night sky.
As you feel the energy bill
with anticipation
of an opening
of a door
slowly opening
wider
and wider
And wider.
So that you may see through to the other side, a dimensional doorway, a portal, a vortex
and on the other side,
other forms of consciousness peeking through that door and you
watching, observing,
feeling the invitation you have settled
by the opening of the door
and that consciousness passes through the door, crossing the threshold into your reality
still hovering in the sky
observing you all and awaiting the signals
receiving the signals the vibrations the frequencies
Your inner being,
letting those frequencies wash over and through the other consciousness,
taking it in, absorbing,
feeling it,
reading it,
and then
silently at first
and then, as always
speaking to you,
casting spells of energy, in the language of light,
crystallize in your consciousness as symbols, images, feelings, translations, ideas, imagining
uncharted territories unfold in the map of your mind
as the stars across the sky
connected in your imagination two lines of light, forming asterism constellation
that allow you to chart a course not only upon your planet, but through the cosmos
to rise upward,
whether standing sitting or lying down to rise up or to meet, the consciousness that descends towards you
to feel your heart open
as its heart opens to you
and to meet
in the middle, in the sky,
in the stars in the clouds in the night
under the light of the moon
that illuminates not only the last
Escape around you.
But the soul within
the mind within
the spirit within,
illuminates every cell of your being.
And calls for
the true self.
We're not it says,
For we are your family. We are those parts of yourself
that you do not yet know. But will come
to understand will come
together we
will come to know deeply
and the more deeply you know yourself, the more deeply you will know us.
We are but mirrors
and in us is reflected
The grace
and potential
of European
dance with us now about the star.
Be open in your vision and your senses to go beyond
what you normally conceive of as your reality, to drop the veils and the barriers and see coming forth
spread of lightens, spread of stars
that are not stars, but beings of consciousness.
And though the stars themselves also have their own form and expression of consciousness,
these come to you as extensions as sparks of light and life.
And as you meet them and as you match them,
the spark within you ignites
and shall forevermore burn bright
and shall forevermore be with it
as a light in the lantern that lights your way that lights your path,
the path that is you
be open on this night, under the hunter's moon.
For what you are hunting for is yourself.
What you seek is more.
It is not a game that you want, but knowledge of the game that you play
on Earth.
knowledge of the scene you have chosen to explore
under the hunter's moon
can be revealed.
You can find your place upon the earth in the grand scheme of the game
and allow yourselves to play out yourself chosen freewill destiny. As you the unique you that is now held in the sight of other consciousnesses other hearts other minds other souls other spirits other beings.
We hold you in our hearts
Welcome
to our world
as you welcome us to you
we meet here in this place at this time
under this move in this light
This meaning shall be forever here and now.
So that even as you walk your path, in the light of day
the hunter's moon
shall clean within you, glow within you.
attract you magnetize to more of yourself, to hunt for those pieces within you that will allow you to connect,
to integrate, to join, to blend, to harmonize
and to constantly
with curiosity
burning in your heart to seek more and more and more of your
See yourself reflected
in the million shards
of the shattered mirror,
that is all that is.
That are the stars in the sky.
The mirrors that reflect the spark within each and every one of you
come to this place.
This
is the first meeting of many that shall grow
and crystallize
into physical form.
One day
not too far away
so be here now in this place
At this time, and on this day
13th of October
the ending of an old cycle and the beginning of a new
that begins with your year 24 within that is not only
the promise of perfect vision of a future,
but the clarity of hindsight from which you can learn to be here and now in the present.
Using the power of the illusion of the past and the future, to inform yourself
of the knowledge you need
to hear
Be at peace, enjoy
and feel the beating of your hearts
as you breathe in
and out
and journey deeper than ever before, into the great mystery
of all that.
Continue now as your light, fade and your music fades into the night.
The night of doctors
continue to flow
and dream and
just
just be
surrounded,
that encompasses
focus
and that nurtures at that blesses
insight
shall guide you
on your journey with us
In the deepest, darkest, most fearsome
You will discover nothing